[Music]
fresh from disney's content minds in
outer burbankia
come season two of a show that's either
the greatest thing we've ever seen or
live action star wars has lowered our
expectations so much
basic competence feels like seeing the
face of god
it's glorious the mandalorian
season two suit up for more mandalorian
the show that combined the world of star
wars the feel of old samurai films
and the emotional core of reddit's r
slash all community
in a winning mix that keeps things
simple and doesn't overstay
its welcome so you can be sure to sit
they'll launch enough spin-offs to kill
the magic for good next year
you know there's a reason we don't eat
birthday cake every day disney keep
feeding us the same thing and we will
reject it
unless it's marvel or animated musicals
or pixar movies about giving up on your
dreams
okay fine you win stuff my mouth full of
cake mouse daddy
rejoin the mandalorian the galaxy's most
dangerous never nude
but this time he'll break his only rule
about giving face
as he quests to deliver this tiny meme
generator over to a jedi
all while bonding ever deeper with baby
yoda over their shared love
of murder
and yes we know his name isn't
technically baby yoda anymore
kroger but let's stick with baby yoda
grogu
baby yoda grogu baby yoda
grogu he's the secret love child of yoda
and yatta okay
clap them cheeks yoda dude cannon that
is
are you ready to watch some space cops
make some deals with each other
then you'll thrill when mando makes a
deal with this marshall
help me kill it i'll give you the armor
deal and strikes a deal with the tuscan
raiders for help
we've struck a deal but when a deal goes
wrong on the way to finding a jedi lady
the deal
is off this wasn't that part of the deal
he'll try to forge a deal with some
fellow mandalorians
you're changing the terms of the deal
and cut a quick deal with ming na
i owe you from last time we have a deal
before he wraps up that deal with her
and boba fett
then our deal is complete that's in
addition to any bargains promises or
propositions he'll make along the way
we can strike a bargain you made me a
promise and i held up my end
i have a proposition that may interest
you then what's in it for me screw
credits
the real currency of star wars is the
pinky swear
remember all the interesting and
original side characters you met last
season
they're back at least for now but
they'll make room for all new faces
and by new i mean really old like
the most popular characters from the
clone wars series
the most popular character from empire
strikes back
and the most popular character from star
wars
it's official no one in star wars gets
to die or retire anymore
this season's most meaningful death was
when they killed off a merchandising
opportunity
so enjoy this action-packed journey
alongside a hardened killer with a heart
of gold
and a soft baby with a heart of darkness
as favro and filoni deliver the second
best star wars experience
ever made for television but you all
know what's still number one
no not clone wars no not rebels
i'm talking about the intro to the
droids cartoon come on
[Applause]
oh man that's such a bop starring
daft honk my buddy my buddy
wherever i go he goes ranger of the new
republicans
dawson's geek princess leia agents of
shan
lone wolf with club moth diver
darkness no parents red sox leader
standing by
stormtroopers giving themselves away
all right we'll check it out five three
eight seven three eight nine follow me
call in reinforcements
value continues to rise others with
vesgar have been through here
the best car belongs to the mandalorians
it cannot cut through pure vascular
the best car is ours frisk
pure best car unreasonably convenient
maps and blueprints
this is a map of tatooine before the war
you got mos eisley most espa an upper on
this region
most pell go we're here this entire area
is the green zone completely safe
but over on this side is the problem
this is what you're talking about right
yeah it's the uh refinery right there
they're held in cold storage in this
cargo bay
it's not the scale i think it is
it can't be that's too big if your 98
civic hatchback was a spaceship
and my deep fake kills on the droid
standing guard
the masked slinger
says here you're from alderaan did you
lose anyone
[Music]
uh yeah chief i'm gonna guess you did
hey it's that guy from the apex legends
trailer
the llama here llamas are nature's
greatest warriors
i'm not a pheasant plucker i'm a
pheasant plucker's son
and i'm only plucking pheasants to the
pheasant plucking's dawn
taco tuesday